The next guest, is one of
the highest rated chefs
in the world and just this week,
the second season of his
show, Hell's Kitchen,
premiered on Fox.
Let's take a look.
Move your arse!
Come on, Elfie.
I wouldn't be standing here
if I didn't believe in you.
Shut it down!
Stand here!
Yes, chef.
[Gordon] Walnuts are with this scallops.
(plate breaks)
I'm waiting on--
Shut the (beep) up, you donkey!
Thank you so much, (beep) Off.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm not bringing him out here.
Let's go to commercial, I
don't wanna talk to him.
Please welcome, Gordon Ramsay.
(clapping and cheering)
Hi, good to see you.
Good to see you.
All right.
Right, um.
Little intimidated,
there's not a lot of time.
I will try not to provoke
you or irritate you.
Right, can you just stand
still for two seconds.
Okay, yes, oohu! (giggles)
All right.
Have you made pasta before?
Oh yeah, pasta.
[Gordon] Yes.
I've made pasta, not pasta, but-
Right, flour on the hands, just like.
(hands clapping)
Flour on the hands. So, we're
gonna make some pasta here.
Okay. Just like that.
Clap, good. Right.
(clapping and whining)
Flour in the center, make a little well.
[Conan] Make what?
[Gordon] Make a little well.
[Conan] Oh, make a little well,
okay.
Dear oh dear.
That's it, right.
Egg yolks in.
[Conan] Egg yolks in.
[Gordon] That's good.
[Conan] Okay, okay.
[Gordon] Use both hands.
[Conan] Okay.
[Conan] Use both hands to do what?
[Gordon] That's it,
start mixing it together.
[Conan] Oh that's disgusting, all right.
[Gordon] Start, there you go.
(Conan and audience groaning)
Right, that's it, now, turn it around.
Ooh, sensual.
[Gordon] A little bit of salt.
[Conan] A little salt there.
[Gordon] A little bit of pepper.
You must have made fresh
pasta before, surely, Conan?
[Conan] No, I never have.
Ramen fried noodles.
[Gordon] No? Here we go.
Right, again.
Keep the well, keep the well.
Keep the well going, all right.
[Gordon] Now, try and get
it really nice and crumby.
[Conan] All right, crumby, crumby.
I don't even know what that means.
[Gordon] Well it's sort of like
a crumble texture, you know.
OK, crumble texture, nice.
There we go.
Right, try and keep it on
the board as well, please.
Thank you, Okay.
OK, all right.
A little passive aggressive
there, but all right.
[Gordon] And any chance you
can sort of move a bit faster?
Okay, oh, okay, yes, I'm try-
alright, little faster there.
Yeah, that's it, good.
Right, right, now get it into a nice ball.
[Conan] Okay.
[Gordon] Little more salt.
(Conan singing)
[Conan] All right, here we go.
Little bit of pepper
OK, a little pepper right there.
Right, now start binding it together.
Binding it together, all right (grunts).
[Gordon] Yeah, there you go, good.
Little bit more.
[Conan] This is good, I've
never made anything before.
This is incredible.
[Gordon] I can see that.
Okay. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Right, mix, no, no.
You bastard. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
You (beep).
Whoa!
(audience exclaiming and clapping)
Whoa. (laughs)
No, don't stop.
All right, OK.
You have to get it right.
Rub it through your hands.
We don't swear in this
country, not on TV (laughs).
[Gordon] Rub in your hands together.
[Conan] Okay, rub it in my
hands together, all right.
Okay, okay.
Right, now you gotta
ball it together, Conan.
Ball it together, all right,
okay, okay.
That's it, there you go.
[Conan] Ball it together it again.
You told me to crumble it,
then you said ball it
together, so I guess.
OK, right.
All right, good, good, good.
Now, that we'll leave it- (laughs).
(audience clapping and cheering)
All right, Okay.
Right, listen, we'll put
this one through the machine.
All right through the
machine, through the machine.
What do I do?
OK, right.
I'll put it through, you wheel it.
Okay.
Come here.
That's it, right, there you go.
All right, just go like this?
Right that's it, now.
Well, any idiot could do this.
[Gordon] Feed it through.
(audience laughing)
[Conan] Use my skills, Gordon!
[Gordon] That hand
through there, lift it up.
[Conan] Oh, Okay, all right, right here?
[Gordon] That's it, nice and long.
[Conan] Oh, beautiful! Oh yeah.
[Gordon] Faster, faster.
(Conan groaning)
There you go, good.
Right, now,
(Conan moaning)
Right now, do you notice
it's getting thinner?
Yes, I did notice that,
it got thinner and longer.
That's right, like you.
(Conan laughing)
Nice.
Here we go, right.
Now, again? OK.
(Conan singing)
Oh, again, take it, okay.
[Gordon] There you go, now, move down.
Okay, I'm having a small heart attack now.
(audience laughs)
Move down!
Okay, oh, no down! Okay stepping it down.
Always hold it like that,
look palm of your hands.
Okay, like this in the air, okay.
That's it. Right, back down.
Okay, then what?
Back in.
Again?
Again.
Alright.
Start turning.
Right here, okay turning.
[Conan] Turning.
[Gordon] Now lift up.
Oh, (beep)!
(audience laughs)
(handle squeaks)
No, wrong hole!
Wrong hole!
Hahaha, wrong hole.
Haha, wrong hole.
(audience laughs)
Right, great, here we go.
Right, come on Conan.
[Conan] Come on Conan, you can do it!
Come on baby, oh baby come on!
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
Good, good, good, good!
Right, okay now, this way.
All right, all right, all
right, all right, okay now.
Now what do we do?
What is this going to be eventually?
I don't even know.
God you are (beep) useless.
(audience cheers)
(Conan laughs manically)
This is going to be ravioli.
Okay now, right, two disks.
Yes, yes, two disks.
Okay, right, listen to me,
here's, here's the moose.
[Conan] Okay.
[Gordon] Okay, so we've got
sweet corn and crab in there.
[Conan] Sweet corn and
crab, uh sort of a moose.
[Gordon] Yeah, almost
like a sort of puree.
[Conan] Would you like me to do that?
I'm quite good at it.
[Gordon] Okay. Off you go.
[Conan] Okay.
(Conan grunts)
It's coming out the top, what am I doing?
(audience laughs)
Why is it coming out of the top?
(audience laughs and claps)
Sorry, sorry, sorry, Gordon!
[Gordon] On the disk!
[Conan] I don't know how to do it.
[Gordon] Push harder!
[Conan] I can't do it, Gordon!
Push harder!
I can't do it!
All right, all right, all right.
[Gordon] Right, from there.
Oh no!
Just one! Just-
No!
(audience laughs)
Watch,
Watch just-
Just stop for two seconds and watch.
That goes on top of there like that
and then bring up the
hands and push it together.
All the air out.
Okay? Okay. So this one goes
on to this one, right here.
Well off we go.
[Conan] You have your way. I have mine.
Who's to say which way is better.
Both equally good.
Right, up in the air,
squeeze all the air out.
Squeezing all the air out, right there.
Let's go and show me.
Right here.
No, no, no, no, no.
What? What did I do wrong?
Wha- wha- wha-, look at that folks.
What do you think?
(audience cheers)
USA, USA, USA.
(audience chants USA)
This one, all right
look, on here like this.
All right, all right.
Lift that over.
This is called a tortellini,
Tortellini.
Yeah so, up like that, half moon.
Okay, half moon.
[Gordon] Come on quick.
Okay, okay, okay, so it's like that.
[Gordon] On this, up, left to right,
right to left, then push, like this.
And we're legally married.
(both laugh)
All right, I think that's
all the time we got.
I don't know what we made there, but,
and then you just drop
this in some boiling water
and something happens right
You drop that in the bin.
(Conan laughs)
I wish I had put it on this finger.
Uh, all right, folks.
(audience reluctantly cheers)
Get in here, you lug.
We're fighting each other on HBO tomorrow.
Check it out.
Hell's kitchen airs
Mondays at nine on Fox.
And this was a lot of fun.
Thank you for doing it.
Gordon Ramsey, everybody.
(audience cheers)